I challenge anyone to find a great
performance by any actor ever that
doesn't start really with text and
understanding the text of the thing
they're doing what are its intentions
what are its goals what are the layers
that are gonna make this person up
primal fear I'm gonna put a caveat on
everything from here forward that my
memory of some of these things is
elusive your own relationship to the
experience is different from people who
enjoy the film because they may have a
more present tense sensitive
I remember weird things I remember
having not had that much experience
working in film realizing that you could
play a very intense scene when they're
doing the coverage in the other
direction and realized that you're out
of gas I remember like in kind of one of
the final courtroom scenes where feeling
like I'd I'd overdone it when it was
like shooting Laura Linney or something
and running to the craft service guy and
going like just get me some caffeine and
I like you know figured out there jack
myself back up on something those like
the rookie mistakes you make everybody
thinks you did this everybody I'm the
only one who believes you and I am that
close so I wanted all out oh right now
right here working with Richard Gere was
like the it was the it was the luckiest
first dance partner I could have had he
he was like veteran part it's like Trent
like the movie training day like he was
such a real comrade in saying this is
great but then like you know in the
subtlest of ways just you know little
pointers little guide in this little
support he was I can't say enough great
about him he was he was so kind to me on
that there was a lot of consternation in
that film about whether he needed to end
up winning whether this was okay that
the end of the film was this body blow
you know of getting
getting sideswiped by this kid he was
the one who like forcefully argue he was
like what is better than me getting
hammered he goes that's what makes this
work he was he didn't want to he didn't
want to win he didn't wanna you know he
knew in a weird way that part of the
pleasure of the end was the smug
polished guy getting sideswiped founders
you know it's one of those things you
look left you look great like what was
the last really good poker movie and
yeah and and there wasn't one then and
then and also some sometimes you just
get this thing of like Matt's doing it
well I'll uh that'd be fun he's great
what Turturro is gonna do it what
Malkovich is gonna do it like come
Martin Landau is gonna do oh my god you
know it's like we're hanging out on the
corner on eighth Avenue and listening to
Martin Landau tell stories like that's
like as good as kids were they allow
people like you places like this you
know what there's a ghost when you get
yourself a job then you can be my vo how
about that work I think has lots of
literary ancestors worms like Johnny boy
and mean streets worm is like the friend
you that if you didn't have roots you
wouldn't be friends with him now you
know what I mean it's like he's in
Shakespeare he'd be puck you know he's
he's he's mischief he's trouble i'm
airinas fix the film was like even the
poster was iconic it was a Shakespearean
type of a story by design it was it was
tragedy that's how we talked about it
that's how when David and I worked on
the script for months months months we
were taking this incredible scenario and
this idea to imagine him as a latter-day
Venice Beach Macbeth you know and a
fellow here's this person who like a lot
of those great
classical tragic heroes has enormous
gifts he's not some cracker he's he's
he's smart he's forceful he loves his
family he has qualities of leadership he
he doesn't suffer fools he's got like
you know we used to say like he is like
the qualities of a general you can see
within him
the things he could could have been but
he's overtaken by rage are kind of you
know ambitious idea at the time was if
what those plays and Greeks and sheiks
we're trying to do is say hey people can
learn a lesson literally a cathartic
lesson from the fall of macbeth because
of ambition the you know a fellow
jealousy like let's look at someone who
ruins all of the potential in his life
because of rage
you know like who let's rage destroy
everything that he that could have been
good in his life I don't think the tape
showed that at all you didn't think so
and what you're an authority ma Murray
what do you think well I did think that
the police use their clubs rather
excessively who are you to say what's
excessive I think it was totally
appropriate I loved working with beverly
d'angelo and Elliott Gould those fans
that dinner those things that the dinner
table were incredibly like visceral and
Verity and improvisational and you have
to have a canoe have to create a special
kind of a sense of Alliance and Trust
like everybody knows we're telling this
story for our reason we have an
objective with this we have a message
with this that's we hope a humanist one
like a thing because you're gonna go to
some places and you don't want to be
self-conscious about it so for me being
the one who was having to like obviously
like almost improvisationally rip at
with these horrible you know rage filled
tire aides at people you when you have
actors and when you feel a sense of like
a safety zone a support in a safe zone
in which to
explore all that it's important this
isn't our neighborhood it's a
battlefield we're on a battlefield
tonight make a decision are we gonna
stand on the sidelines quietly standing
there while our country gets raped the
guts of the whole thing we're David
McKenna is like great great writing
nobody like Swans in and starts making
up a character from some intuitive level
you you have to there's a text there's a
script there's a director with there's
an idea there's a whole set of ideas and
you have to engage from the point of
view of what is this piece like what is
it saying what is it doing
what's the tonality of it is it highly
stylized as it's supernatural istic what
are the layers that are gonna make this
person up and sometimes honestly
wardrobe can become the right set of
boots we'll find you the characters
physicality faster than than any like
sense memory exercise you know what I
mean it's it's very there's many many
many many triggers to the process of
finding what becomes you know quote
unquote character I think high club
Fincher one time said that it was a film
about a serious subject made by deeply
unserious people which is sort of true I
mean honestly the it was a marathon but
it really was characterized by by a lot
of laughter I think my abiding memory of
the whole thing whatever was
quote-unquote hard about is that we were
just having a ball
Fincher is funny Brad is funny helena is
really funny Andy Walker who came in and
did a lot of great rewrites on it was
every there was a lot of funny people on
that movie and there was a fun dark
sensibility of sticking a fork in things
you know and it was it was fun how are
you doing
I don't know that I've ever been
involved in a situation where a text was
better suited to a director's very
unique talents I mean he what he did on
that movie technically was just a
jaw-dropper to watch on a day-in day-out
basis he was doing things that were just
like so off the wall and an impressive
and innovative and the way that ventures
technical capabilities enhanced the
discombobulation of the experience which
is what the film is about what it just
all it was all snowballing in a way that
was really impressive to watch and we
saw it together finished for the first
time and I think we were just it's one
of those things you just go wow we're
gonna will always have this one you know
what I mean like it was great you hope
you get a couple of those in a whole
career you know what I mean
20 foot power spike we was one of the
reasons I got serious about making films
because do the right thing was to me one
of the definitive films of my
coming-of-age I had an enormous enormous
impact on literally like what I thought
was the reason to make movies like it
changed my aspirational target and I'd
literally written spike fan letters I
mean I thought he got game was like an
absolute freaking undeclared masterpiece
I thought it was just great and I I
think I wrote him a letter about that
and then when I saw in some way or some
time he came running over and we got
into it and then you know we started
looking for something to do Oh Falls to
jail for 15 life you think Bush and
Cheney didn't know about that give me up
break I think spike was not gonna make
that movie in the aftermath of 9/11 and
not deal with the melancholy that was
sitting on his town spike makes films
about that moments he's living in he
makes films about the tensions in his
neighborhood he makes films about what's
the moral challenge of the moment we're
living in
and there and you know and I think spike
just was drawn to the 25th hour because
we all were just because it's a great
morality tale it's like does
responsibility for someone's decisions
ripple out our others responsible for
someone falling you know well I think we
shot the 25th hour and 26 days I think
it was the shortest schedule I've ever
shot a film on it was the shortest
schedule I've ever shot a film on and
and it's a function of Spike's
preparation he's one of the most
prepared directors and part of that it's
rehearsal he roasted like a play you
know five or six weeks 9:00 to 5:00
every day like a play and fill an hour
in heaven we were like this is this is
everything we love you know motherless
Brooklyn it's based on a novel called
motherless Brooklyn by a great Brooklyn
writer named Jonathan leave him it's a
story about a very unusual underdog he's
a guy who is afflicted with Tourette's
syndrome and obsessive-compulsive
disorder and he works he has a place in
the world within a detective agency in
Brooklyn and a mentor Bruce Willis who
who sort of understands him and
understands that he has many strange
gifts within this condition of his
affliction and when something bad
happens to that one friend and mentor
who gives him his place in the world it
sets him off on this journey of revenge
and also puzzle solving to figure out
what happened and it sort of leads him
into this vast world of powerbrokers in
the social history of what was happening
to New York in the 50s it's in the
traditions of noir I hope like Chinatown
or Big Sleep for many of the things that
look at the underbelly of how things
really happened in American life but at
the same time it really is a character
portrait it's a character study about an
underdog finding his way into his own
kind of empowerment I think I get
something wrong with me that's the first
thing to know Red's my head
I got to head to my heads man i twitch
and shout a lot the thing about
directing and acting is that you get to
be the sculptor of your own performance
which is great with something as tricky
as a character with Tourette syndrome
where you're gonna want as an actor to
feel liberated to try a lot you're the
ultimate arbiter of the of the
calibration of your performance that's
very nice there's a certain bubble of of
illusion that actors like to maintain
together even even though there's all
this technical distraction going on
around them and when you're a director
you're part of that technical
distraction so you're kind of you're
bursting the bubble that as actors you
like to create together and probably my
biggest anxiety about directing and
acting was the way I would compromise
the experience for the other actors of
acting with me but the answer to that is
to get like stone-cold pros people who
are like tradecraft professionals and
really bring intrinsically to it more
than you could ever hope for you know
more than you even imagined Bruce Willis
Alec Baldwin Willem Dafoe Gugu and Gotha
raw bobby cannavale a Jerry Jones
Michael K Williams I mean and it keeps
going there's a there's a lot I went to
with the exception of Gugu who's my my
British import because she's such a
liminal new talent her she's just I
think emergent into like people's
consciousness which is I what I wanted
in my lady of mystery my figure of
mystery but but the large bulk of
everyone I went to on this was kind of
my cadre of New York theater actors that
I know I've worked with have
relationships with it's um and who I
think have a certain kind of a New York
shorthand if you will do you remember
what I said
she doesn't know she doesn't know what
don't I know
it's a total consumption it's a total
creative engagement it's um he's very
very challenging and I love so many of
the store the dimensions of storytelling
from photography to music to sound it
it's such a rich opportunity to play
with all these little creative
compartments of your brain